The joe rogan experience,
how did it humble you?
Like in what way?
Because I realized that
when we were,
let's say when I'm,
when I film a documentary and I'm
[inaudible],
uh,
I from a documentary called [inaudible]
Negra and um,
and Cape Verde two years ago.
Aqua Negro.
Yeah.
Iguana.
Does that mean black water?
Yes,
in Portuguese.
And then,
uh,
we were there for about five weeks,
five or six weeks.
And then the living conditions were
pretty bad
and there was no grocery stores around
and we had to catch my own food.
And then it was really a self sufficient
type of chip.
In the first week.
I remember the only thing I could focus
on was,
oh God,
this is,
this is terrible.
The,
we don't have a showered is no hot
water,
bathroom are disgusting,
I'm starving is nothing around.
And then all you can thing is like,
how will you comfort is gone.
And after week,
that's the,
the focus change on the good things that
we're seeing around us and why having
nothing all of a sudden then I was like,
oh,
I actually now for the first time in my
life can take the time to realize what's
good around me and then how we were
having fires with the neighbors and then
how we were offering and fish and we
were thinking,
oh,
you know,
if I give this guy two fish is going to
eat one today and one tomorrow.
But no,
the inviting the neighbors to share when
they made sure that it was like a whole
like community sentence to all of it.
And I was like,
wow,
I've been living in London for six
years.
I don't even know the name of my
neighbor.
And it's,
it's,
it's bad.
It's not,
it's not a way of living that I want.
It's not focusing in the right thing is,
and it's,
it was that,
that that's in that way,
you know,
it's realize how much of,
how much of an asshole we actually
became and I just didn't want to do
that.
The moment the cameras went off,
Masa waukee twisted a spoon and started
getting it to twist.
The producer had a complete mental
breakdown.
Now,
up to this point,
I'm just thinking,
this is tricks,
right?
It's not,
it's not that big of a deal.
He starts screaming,
yelling that randy's evil should never
have listened to randy.
He would've got this on tape if it
wasn't for Randy.
And he looks down and he's got a wet
spot on the front of his pants and he
looks down and he says,
I just had a demonic ejaculations like
literally,
and he's having his mental breakdown.
I go and I have to spend the night,
which was not a bad thing.
She was quite pleasant to look at his,
his assistant.
I had to spend the night with her in her
room because randy was calling her.
I'm not randy.
I mean,
uh,
Tony editable calling or the producer
was calling her consistently screaming
and yelling about randy and the skin the
fuck up.
You can't just gloss over the fact that
guy just nutted in his pants.
He was yelling,
you're just gonna.
He had a med.
It's a mental breakdown.
I mean,
it's like a hot orgasm and your pants
during a mental note.
I didn't it.
He did it.
They should document that.
That's more impressive than banging a
spoon.
I should have said.
Yep.
That's my psychic ability working right
there.
I mean,
that doesn't make any sense.
So he,
he tells you he has an a jackie in his
pants.
He in front of everybody,
he says it's a demonic ejaculation.
He straight up says,
I am the Arctic ejaculations.
Seems like a together guy with
definitely got a head on his shoulders.
He was a producer for us.
I think it was BBC,
if I'm not mistaken.
He was doing a documentary for them,
so yeah.
Well he's fucking crazy,
huh?
He finished a documentary,
so,
oh well,
yeah,
definitely.
It wasn't crazy then.
As long as you finish this documentary.
Well,
he believed in psychic phenomena.
He also believed the demon made him come
in his pants.
That is true.
How are we going to do this calorie?
What are we going to do?
We filled our BC up.
When I run out of air,
I'm now thinking in my mind,
how am I going to die,
Joe?
Right?
Tell my wife,
tell my kid I'm not fucking,
I'm coming home now.
I got to fucking realize how am I going
to die?
I have a notepad that you carry in your
pocket to draw and write on.
I'm thinking,
what?
What?
What are you going to say?
What's your,
what's your letter going to be?
You're writing a fucking death later.
You're awake.
You're a fighter.
We figured this out.
They don't fucking find a way to Kuwait.
You fucking bitch.
He's a conversation.
I'm having one.
And I said,
well,
I'm in fucking complete panic morning,
complete darkness thinking that there's
no,
this is how people die.
What the fuck are you doing?
You're going to write a letter to your
fucking kid and tell her how you,
how you fucked up.
I'm sorry.
Daddy's not coming home.
So I'm fucking thinking I'm not going to
drown.
They're not going to breathe my last
breath.
So I'm going to breed this BC that just
fill up with air and I'm a fucking
breathe it until the oxygen level no
longer happens and I'd just pass out.
That's,
that's my,
that's what I've come to realize how I'm
going to die.
I'm going to fucking just slip away and
pass out,
keep breathing the same air until
I go away and I start thinking,
you fucking piece of shit.
You're,
you're giving up.
You're having the legitimate
conversations with myself while fucking
a complete panic.
Like you're,
you're going to quit that.
You're writing a letter and you're gonna
fucking breathe your last air until you
pass out you fucking pussy.
You're a fighter.
Figured the fuck out.
So I'm upside down.
I'm crawling on the ceiling.
I remember when I came in,
we came in the big cave and there's like
a huge fucking crack that runs along the
top turn.
Both my watch off now at this point,
because they're giving off light and I
kill my light.
And I said that crack in a fucking lead
to the surface.
That cracks going to fucking give us
something.
So I just call,
start panicking.
Me Panicking Leni again because I'm
panicking.
I don't know what to do.
I'm sucking air and a fucking breathing
hard and I'm hyperventilating and crying
on the ceiling,
crying on the ceiling,
looking for this fucking cracking.
God Damn it.
I found it.
I found the crack and I followed the
crack and the crack got bigger and all
of a sudden I see fucking glow,
like green glow,
crawl and crawl on.
Find it.
Try to get up.
My tags are too big.
I can't fucking get out of the little
hole.
Can't get out of the hole.
I'm fucking big.
Be Big,
big fucking hitting,
screaming,
freaking out.
Calm down.
Cowboy.
Calm down,
Kelly.
This is the way.
Calm the fuck down.
Reel it in.
We're here.
We made it
grab control.
Fall the cracks and more opens up out.
Boom.
There's theK fucking I'm out
made it.
You're coming home.
You are doug about.
Wow.
That was the feeling.
Meanwhile,
my guys out there,
I can't be mad at him because he
panicked.
He grabbed line.
He fucking ran out the hole.
He looks at me and he says,
MMM,
so we're not diving together ever again,
Ali.
I said,
no,
that was it.
That was it.
And I texted my girl,
I love you baby.
And uh,
they was fucking scary moment,
but daddy's coming home.
What is it like to have Jordan Peterson
has a dad.
Is it weird?
Do you have to check yourself
constantly?
Make sure you're on,
on steady ground?
And I'd say anything ridiculous.
No,
not at all.
None at all.
I didn't realize it was weird until I
went away to university and then kind of
saw like just when I was away for a
while and then when I came back to the
house,
especially because the house was full of
like paintings and masks and statues and
like 32 different paint colors and they
came back and was like,
oh,
maybe he's a bit eccentric.
No,
he's definitely eccentric.
Um,
we were talking off air about what it
was like to watch your dad to become
famous and,
and become famous.
And in his 50s,
right?
Like,
yeah,
I hope 54 55 that's when he became
famous before that.
Relatively unknown,
respected professor.
One issue with this one transgender
bill,
the,
the preferred pronouns bill,
and then boom,
off to the races.
Yeah,
it's strange.
It was,
yeah,
it was super weird,
especially how the media was portraying
him and how what was actually happening
at the events wasn't what was being
portrayed in the media.
So that was weird to watch.
And then people recognizing him on the
street is strange.
It's,
yes.
When you say what,
what happened in real life was not,
was what was being portrayed like what
was different?
Um,
mostly what he was saying.
So most of what he said is on film
anyway.
So you can go to youtube and see what
he's been saying.
Like not,
there's not like some secret that's
going around,
but what's been portrayed has been so
much more negative than what he's
actually said.
Or they'll take like sound bites and
just weave a story that isn't quite
true.
Which I didn't read it for some reason.
I now it looks silly,
but for some reason I just thought that
what the media was portraying was honest
always.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
Yeah.
And it's not,
they're trapped in there and they can't.
Right get out.
They,
they didn't have an
option to say,
I don't want to see him.
It's really interesting.
All the different spins though.
All the different women spins,
you know?
And W one,
one really bizarre spin that I saw was
this one was saying that this is
indicative of the problem of all comedy
clubs and aggressive male audience and
women sitting there feeling threatened,
not being able to use their voice.
I'm like user voice.
Like what are you gonna heckle?
Oh yeah.
They were saying like,
like you would be more empowered if
there were more women.
So you could heckle is,
that's not cool.
Like you're not supposed to do that at a
comedy club have you don't like someone
just don't laugh,
you know?
Right.
But like,
I mean this one was,
here's the thing,
it's not your job or it's not your place
to say that you don't like someone when
the other people do like it.
You know,
if you were right,
if you're going to get,
I'm going to walk out.
Yeah.
Just like you're going to see a movie,
like you're an audience member.
The deal is you're not there to perform.
The audience is there to just sit there
and laugh or not laugh,
right?
But don't be rude to the other people
that are enjoying it.
So as soon as you break your
sensibilities above the rest of the
audience,
well,
you are a problem,
right?
You've made,
if you decide like,
hey,
I didn't like this,
I'm going to go home and write about it.
That's totally your prerogative.
That's fine.
Get up and walk out.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Go somewhere else and talk about it on
stage yourself.
Yeah.
No,
nothing wrong with any of those things.
Yeah.
But this,
this one woman's take was like,
women don't feel like they have,
uh,
they can,
they have the ability to speak out about
it.
I'm like,
speak out.
Like,
so you're saying like to heckle,
Hey,
I don't want you on stage.
I know everything about you and your
story.
I talk to me.
I want you to perform in front of me.
Even those other people are laughing.
Right?
And th th that these aggressive men were
yelling,
good to see you back.
Louie.
Aggressive men.
Like,
okay.
That's like,
there's a framing of this and this is
one of its,
becomes this male versus female framing
that sort of represents aggressive men,
sexual men doing things to women.
They don't want,
the women are sitting there in silence.
They don't want to be there and they
don't have a voice because they feel
overwhelmed and out overpopulated or,
uh,
eh.
Outnumbered.
Okay.